hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
the only site on the internet that does
physics right
and more than right uh we do it
rationally that's that's the difference
anyways today we're going to be talking
a little bit about the moonies and the
flat earthers we have a couple of those
and um
specifically we're going to be talking
about belief
what in the world is belief
well we held the other day that
knowledge is belief the question is
whether belief is knowledge
and a lot of people have obviously a lot
of problems
equating those two words
okay so we're gonna deal with that
and we're gonna start with our uh
science critic
we can't say much about extinction
because uh we don't know what's going on
really over there in ukraine and that's
probably going to have some effect
especially on the global economy under
european economy especially so until
that develops a little more i don't
think we can say anything about either
the war or the global economy we have to
wait and see
uh so let's move on to our science
critic
father made a video
uh criticizing the scientific method can
you believe that
of course he's entitled to do that and
the question is whether his arguments
have any validity okay
and so let's move on with that
i hope all of you can hear me properly
and fine uh let me know if you can see
me and and hear me okay
please confirm sometimes i talk it it
turns out i'm cut off by youtube or
someone
okay so let's move on with our science
critic okay this is what he had to say
specifically about energy
what is energy
is energy a thing
and if it's not
can
a thing contain
energy
you know like uh you contain uh a water
in a bucket or something like that is
that what energy is something that you
can hold and contain that's going to be
the issue okay this is what he had to
say and this is what is at stake okay
yeah yeah planar walk whatever his name
is um i'm gonna be addressing issue by
issue
that he raised he raised so many issues
and it's uh really
it was in line with what i was
gonna talk about in science so
i'm gonna
essentially answer his questions and by
answering his
questions his uh
the issues that he raised i think i'm
going to be enlightening people on what
the scientific method really is and
where the current scientific method
taught in schools
is uh is irrational it doesn't conduce
to the questions that people ask people
want to know how gravity works people
want to know how magnetism works and
these people are giving us equations and
irrational explanations
after 400 years of the so-called you
know 17th century scientific revolution
in which they changed the
greek scientific method and they said uh
no we're going to be doing
math in other words measurements and
equations
and we're going to do experiments
and it turns out with all that
we ended up with irrational explanations
in physics in so-called mathematical
physics in the establishment so that's
what we're criticizing and we're saying
that math
that uh mathematical method as we call
it uh or mathematical method
has uh no validity whatsoever it doesn't
answer the questions we're seeking okay
so here let's run with the science
critic let's see what he had to say and
this is
give me a second here so i put them on
okay the questions and issues addressed
in this rebuttal include
is energy a thing
if not
does it make sense in physics to say
that an object can contain energy energy
is not just capacity energy is the
capacity to do work because a lot of
things do have the capacity to do work
that would make them contain energy now
i don't think i've ever heard anyone
define energy as a substance i've
usually heard it in reference to being
contained by something
okay so
so the issue is is energy a physical
object
if an ain't
the question is whether there is
something
physical object
give me a second here
someone's calling me on the phone at a
wrong time
[Applause]
[Music]
get these interruptions
anyways the issue is whether energy is a
physical object
and the question is whether if it's not
a physical object can something contain
energy
in other words if energy is a concept
right
can you contain a concept for the
purposes of physics or are we confusing
ordinary speech with scientific language
that's the issue oh my god
[Applause]
my god
probably gonna get a third call here
anyways the uh
this is what uh what i'm gonna raise
against this uh issue that these people
raised energy uh is defined as the
capacity and in fact this gentleman
defined it as the capacity okay blah
blah blah blah blah we don't care what
comes after the word capacity because
it's irrelevant capacity is what energy
is defined as and capacity is a concept
okay so this is the issue capacity is
not a physical object in other words
it's not a thing it's not a substance
it's not a something okay capacity the
maximum amount
in other words capacity is defined as an
amount
okay
capacity is a concept in a and that's
what energy is a concept okay so energy
is not a physical standalone object you
can't draw a picture of energy
you cannot make up you cannot take a
snapshot of energy you cannot show me
in a picture
what energy is all what's
when you say what is this what is that
what is a table what is a tree
you should be able to draw it that's the
answer to a what question you can't say
what is love not in science not in
physics
because love is not a what
okay you can define the word love but
you can't say what is love
that's the issue okay and that's when we
confuse ordinary speech with scientific
language especially the language of
physics physics the nouns have to be
physical objects things
that which has shape not that which you
can define right
okay so uh here we have um
a synthesis of the problem in physics
contain
is a physical word when you say that you
contain something you cannot contain a
concept you cannot say the
the brain contains the mind
for example mind is a concept you can't
say brain contains mind okay you can say
my
brain contains cells uh you know
anything you want something that is
physical okay contains atoms okay
molecules but you can't say it contains
mind
and uh and here's an example you can say
um in ordinary speech you can say i have
a headache
okay
headache is a concept not a physical
object you can't draw a picture of a
headache you can't hold it in your hands
okay
uh you can
have a dime like a dime in your pocket
okay so there's a difference between
having a headache and having a dime
having a concept and having an object
okay
you can say that you can contain water
which is a thing you cannot say that you
can contain love or intelligence that
the you know the brain contains
intelligence you can't say something
like that in physics for the purposes of
physics okay
so
if energy is not a thing then energy
cannot be contained
and this is where the problem really uh
comes in here okay this fellow is saying
energy is equal to capacity this is a
reasoning his line of reasoning okay he
says energy is the capacity okay
okay and so he said things have the
capacity he uses the word have the verb
have
which he takes from ordinary speech he
doesn't realize that he's introducing a
uh
language of ordinary speech suddenly
into physics he's saying things have the
capacity okay
this is an irrational statement in
physics okay so you so then he since he
equated energy with capacity he says
things have in other words contain
energy suddenly he's now containing a
concept called energy okay
and he
reinforces that by saying energy is
contained by things but it's irrational
physics to have a concept to contain a
concept this is where he made his error
okay and this is the same error uh the
establishment makes and everybody out
there makes because they introduce
language of ordinary speech using have
and contain
touch see
and they're talking about concepts okay
and uh so this is this is this is where
the problem is okay so keep that in mind
whenever you use language here we we are
correcting
the language of physics and we hope that
people do not confuse okay
uh ordinary speech with scientific
language we want to make people aware
that there is
a new language out there you'll hear it
in this side probably no other site but
uh be aware that if you're going to be
challenging this site uh we're going to
run into trouble when
when
you raise issues in which you confuse
the language of ordinary speech with the
language of science
okay
okay let's move on to uh the subject of
today which is
belief we have belief
and what is belief well for that um we
start where we left off the other day
which is knowledge we defined knowledge
as belief last time uh we couldn't get
away from the word belief no matter what
how we tried
and people don't like that people want
to think they want to believe
that knowledge and belief are two
different things in their minds they say
well it's not the same
but see in 3 000 years no one has been
able to separate knowledge from belief
or belief from knowledge
and so we said we have to go with the
definitions we have to start a
definition you don't like the fact that
i equate knowledge with belief you have
a single recourse and that is to define
the word knowledge in which you do not
use the word belief or that you do not
use any subjectivity whatsoever because
that takes you into belief
that's the issue
so what happened well uh we have a
winner for the
idiot competition this uh time around
and it starts like this
last time we held that knowledge um
well that philosophy is the love of
wisdom that's how the greeks defined it
essentially that's what the word
philosophy means or how it was
translated love of wisdom okay the
greeks uh they couldn't define knowledge
you know they they were unsuccessful in
the end
in uh specifically plato right he was
unsuccessful unsuccessful in saying
um you know knowledge is
anything other than but
belief okay he he couldn't get out of
that
and so you know uh that's where we are
today because we haven't progressed
uh
an inch
since the days of plato no one has been
able to define
the word knowledge in a way that uh
we can use it scientifically first okay
um
in a way that we allude the word belief
in the word in a way that we can elude
um
subjectivity okay that's the issue okay
so the
grease equated knowledge with belief and
to this day no definite we have no
definition of knowledge and so we stay
with what plato started and ended with
and that's that knowledge is belief you
don't like it well you have one recourse
and
that is to define the word knowledge
without using any subjectivity
whatsoever you can't introduce an
observer or anything like that because
as soon as you introduce that you get
into opinions and their opinions are
beliefs and beliefs are religion they
have nothing to do with science now we
defined it here we define knowledge
in a way that um
that it is
usable as a word we don't have any use
for the word knowledge in science but we
defined what all these people have been
saying for the last 3000 years and that
is how do you prove your knowledge to
someone else
well you prove it by running an
experiment
and you have to predict the outcome of
that experiment without error
and that's what's impossible to do a
hundred percent of the time
so there is no such thing as knowledge
what is knowledge according to us it's
the ability to predict the outcome of an
experiment without error that's the
definition of knowledge of course people
don't like that definition they say well
that's not what we always thought about
knowledge people think that knowledge
has something to do with reading a book
and
learning that you know napoleon went to
waterloo in 1815 and so they say i know
that napoleon went to waterloo in 1815.
now you don't know it because you can't
prove it and you cannot predict it it's
not something of the future something of
the past
and uh all you can do is regurgitate
what you read you have no knowledge
whatsoever no first-hand knowledge of
what happened
in history so you can't say you know
this but that's how we use the word
regularly we we go in front of the three
panel
judges uh at the university and we say i
know that napoleon went to waterloo how
do you know that well because i read it
in a book written by one of you
[Laughter]
okay so you cannot know
that napoleon went to waterloo you can
only know the future the word no only
belongs to the future the ability to
predict the outcome of an experiment
without error and of course there's no
such thing as knowledge because as soon
as you make a prediction
that something's going to happen that
certain result is going to take place in
an experiment there comes the asteroid
destroys the earth
and your prediction does not come true
because you did not know that there was
an asteroid coming to destroy the earth
so that's the issue here okay
okay so uh here we have um
fellow says people had knowledge before
the ancient greeks
what's that got to do with anything okay
uh he thinks that we're saying here that
uh we that the greeks invented the word
knowledge and uh that their definition
doesn't count that there was knowledge
before the greeks and yeah
i think there was knowledge uh i mean
we're going to talk about knowledge in
terms of you know
what the
common notion of knowledge is that it's
something that you know
meaning you believe it strongly
uh you know uh yeah there was knowledge
before the greeks what does this say
about anything
so yeah i think this uh foe won the
idiot composition this week uh
with flying colors okay
uh
what can i say
okay let's move on to uh
explaining a little bit about knowledge
again and let's make sure we understand
that well okay here's a good old plato
and he said
knowledge he defined it essentially as
it's been translated from his book okay
the theaters uh he said now they just
justify true belief that was his uh
final comment on the word knowledge and
it's socrates that's really he's
speaking for socrates okay
and so knowledge uh is justified through
belief but when you look that up is
justified just by by whom by you and so
joseph has just another opinion but it's
belief what is true well what is true to
you is a lie is false to your neighbor
or a lie to your neighbor okay so that's
also a belief that's a personal belief
it's an opinion and so knowledge ends up
being belief belief belief
that's it now that's as far as you get
with that uh what is knowledge according
to
plato it's just a strongly held belief
when you have a belief you just have a
belief but when you have uh knowledge
you have a strongly
based belief that means you believe in
it very very strongly and no one's going
to take you out of that because you know
it
okay that's what's happening here
so people think that knowledge is uh
something that we know like
oh uh you know i press the button and
the light turns on they think that's
knowledge
they say yeah we know it's gonna turn on
it turns out that you know the electric
circuit is failing you press the button
and nothing turns on
well you did not know
that
the electric circuit was failing in your
house and so your prediction does not
come true
okay and we can go with a million
scenarios similar to that one okay so no
uh now it's just a strongly held belief
you know for sure that your neighbors
been doing this and this and that and it
turns out that maybe you find out later
on that your knowledge was just a belief
that he wasn't in fact
doing anything that you thought he was
doing
and so on down the line so there's no
such thing as knowledge okay again
knowledge the only way you show it to
someone else is by running an experiment
and proving your knowledge by predicting
exactly the outcome
of that experiment the results of that
experiment and we can't even do that not
even god can do that because uh that
means he would have to already have been
in the future
and know exactly what's going to happen
because he's watched the movie
but by doing so he turns you
into a cartoon character that has no
free will it means that
uh there's a script and you have no way
of avoiding the script because god
already knows everything that's going to
happen
the the blocked universe that relativity
has that everything has already happened
and all that you are doing is walking in
footsteps
that is in a script that you cannot
avoid you're just bugs bunny you know
doing whatever the author uh the
the
person who drew
or
wrote the script
bugs money cannot act outside the script
and that's what you are if the future
has already happened and if the future
has not already happened we don't know
the future we cannot predict the future
100
certain
you know and so there is no such thing
as knowledge but that would be the
definition of knowledge
okay a fellow makes a comment he says uh
knowledge gnosis has been confused with
this
uh-huh he says that this uh
word gnosis okay
is uh
confused many times with knowledge now a
lot of people don't understand exactly
what nelses is okay
and so if you look it up is a feminine
greek noun which means knowledge or
awareness
it is often used for personal knowledge
compared with intellectual knowledge
okay now in spanish we have uh
two words
conocer
and saber
saber means to know when you know
something but conocer is a word that
doesn't exist in the united in in
english okay uh we don't there there is
no word for conocer
and uh it's more like acquaintance with
okay that you're acquainted with someone
for example so you so in english you say
um i know joe okay
and we don't use the word uh
saber for that we use the word conocer
you have the same thing in russian you
say you have the same thing in german
okay
um
and there is no such
uh word in english in english they use
no for everything okay so
that's essentially
what this fellow was pointing to that
gnosis is not the same thing as
knowledge gnosis is more like you see
there canon in
german and conocer in spanish and so on
okay but there is no such word in
english
uh just for your information there okay
and uh so
what is belief then because we said if
knowledge is belief if plato held that
knowledge is justified true belief
people don't like to hear that but then
what is belief and how does it differ
from knowledge
if any at all
well one thing you'll notice if you look
up the word belief okay whether you look
it up in the dictionary in an
encyclopedia or whatever you'll find one
thing and that's that they never use the
word knowledge to define belief
but when they do it in reverse when they
define the word knowledge they do define
it is believe you'll see the word belief
in the explanation in the justification
you'll see the word belief somewhere in
there
and so there is a a problem
that on the one hand you know
knowledge is equal to belief they have
the word belief in the definition of
knowledge somewhere in there or any
explanation but when it's in reverse
when you look at belief they talk
nothing at all about knowledge
okay and that's a problem because you're
saying hold it knowledge is belief but
belief is not knowledge
in fact when you look at a sin in them
when you look at a synonym of knowledge
you'll find you won't find
the word belief in there but you'll find
the word unbelief
so they do use the word
unbelief as an antonym but you will not
find a synonym uh in of knowledge as
being belief
okay so we have the this inconsistency
as well keep that in mind if you look up
these words okay so where do we go well
let's go to one place that analyzed the
word knowledge quite well and that's a
stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
which
as i said before never defined the word
philosophy and therefore we have no
definition of the word philosophy you
know love of wisdom
okay so here it is this is what the
stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
uh says about knowledge about
belief says contemporary anglophone
philosophers of mine generally use the
term belief to refer to the attitude we
have roughly whenever we have something
to be the case or regard as true
to believe something in this sense
needn't involve actively reflecting on
it nor does the term belief in standard
philosophical usage imply any
uncertainty or any extended reflection
about the matter in question in other
words when we say belief it's not like
we're pondering
in every case right
anything deeply you can say you believe
in god versus in the existence of god
and maybe that person pondered it deeply
and said well i believe god exists you
know he might say that
but
it when you say you know i believe that
i'm going uh this uh weekend on vacation
you know you may not be really
reflecting on it you may not have any
uncertainty about you have not reflected
up on it you know in any deep matter
in any deep way
okay so it says many of the things we
believe in the relevant sense are quite
mundane that we have heads that is the
21st century that a coffee mug is on the
desk forming beliefs is thus one of the
most basic and important features of the
mind yeah
i think we all have beliefs okay uh of
different kinds
and they can continue here say the
mind-body problem for example so central
to philosophy of mind is in part the
question of whether and how a purely
physical organism can have beliefs
much of the epistemology revolves around
questions about when and how our beliefs
are justified
or qualify as knowledge okay the first
notion that belief
is related to knowledge okay and that's
because knowledge is defined as belief
but not because belief is defined as
knowledge okay and that's where people
more or less draw the line people say
well belief is not really knowledge
isn't it i mean and a lot of people go
into technology and they say well we
know how to build something
and that was the first uh
notion
that uh plato attacked uh socrates you
know
theaters uh
uh
he he attacked that that a craftsman who
knows how to build something that does
not qualify as knowledge so anyone using
technology and saying well we know how
to build things and we know that a
computer works and all that stuff that's
not knowledge okay that can easily be
torn down for this you gotta read the
theaters and find out what uh socrates
first argument is against
uh this notion of technology you know
craftsmanship being equated to knowledge
okay so uh we're not going to get into
that but just look it up look up um
the
thedas and you'll find what socrates
argument is there what is the catholic
encyclopedia
of philosophy say remember that catholic
uh they deal with belief every day what
do they say belief is i mean they talk
about the belief in god right that's
what they uh vouch for okay so here it
is it says catholic encyclopedia what is
belief the state of mind by which is uh
sense to propositions not by reason of
their intrinsic evidence
but because of authority
uh is that where we draw the line
between knowledge and belief uh
authority the fact that you
in the case of belief you accept things
through authority
well you know all this knowledge that
mathematical physics has
you know here we are several generations
later after einstein and niels bohr
relativity and quantum mechanics right
and how do all these people learn if not
through authority uh enforced through
the universities
you know you you go take the test you
better
uh if you want to pass it you have
better
parent to par party line and if you want
to graduate and you want to get a phd
well hopefully uh you know you don't go
against the grain you don't go against
the establishment okay so
yeah people swallow everything through
authority and what do they say there
that that's uh
so yeah a lot of the so-called knowledge
that we have today especially in
mathematics in physics and mathematical
physics has to do with authority
and so yeah again knowledge is uh
belief if uh belief is swallowed through
authority
and says the objects of belief also are
of a nature similar to those of
knowledge
okay again belief they related to
knowledge why because there's this issue
of knowledge being justified through
belief
opinion and doubt no criterion of
division can be found in them okay they
have not figured out what knowledge is
really other than belief and so they
can't figure out how to define knowledge
without referring to belief and that
applies to the catholic encyclopedia but
remember something about that you know
they have a stake in equating
knowledge with belief because they say
hey i believe but by that i mean that i
know that god exists
you see where that's coming from so they
love the fact that uh knowledge is
equated with belief that nobody has done
anything better than what plato did in
the last you know three thousand years
ago
okay
so here it is uh catholic encyclopedia
continues says knowledge cannot strictly
speaking be defined
that's how they start their argument
that's great love it that means that
they don't know what knowledge is
because they can't define it no one can
out there so before you attack
my notion that knowledge is equal to
belief
begin with your definition i need a
perfect definition
that does not include the word belief or
opinion or you know anything related to
religion to subjectivity okay
the consciousness of an object
supposes a judgment
truth and certitude are conditions of
knowledge okay so these are the three
things that they say are involved with
knowledge and if you go right there
consciousness uh judgment truth and
certitude what are you talking about
you're talking about belief opinion okay
subjectivity a man may be mistake error
for truth and give his unreserved ascent
to a false statement
okay so if you have knowledge
uh maybe your knowledge is in error
that's what they're saying there and so
you your knowledge may be false meaning
it was uh your opinion all along it was
uh your belief okay he may then be under
the irresistible illusion that he knows
and subjectively the process is the same
as that of
knowledge okay
but as an essential condition is lacking
namely conformity of thought with
reality okay
so that they're uh so that there we have
only the appearance of knowledge
we have what the semblance of knowledge
we think we know but it turns out that
we be believed all along okay and again
uh like i like to say is mother nature
knows for sure if there was a guy named
napoleon and whether he fought at
waterloo in 1815 she knows for a fact
god knows uh the devil knows all these
people that you know father universe
they all know because they have it in
their filing cabinet what exactly
happened okay they know exactly what
happened at different points in time
we don't know
we could only we have no access to the
filing cabinet all we have is what our
forefathers told us through books and
you know maybe by word of mouth
so we don't know for sure that napoleon
existed and then he went to waterloo we
don't know
we just believe it because our
forefathers pass that information
through to us through books
primarily
the people who know are you know these
gods uh mother nature and father you
know they know they but we don't have
access to their filing cabinet so we
they have the facts we only have
statements of the facts of what we think
is is true okay
of what we think is a fact but we don't
have the exact fact because your fact
could be different than my fact
okay we have we might have different
facts different um starting point we
make different assumptions
okay
and so we don't we don't really have
knowledge all we have is belief you have
your belief you i have my belief and we
introduce them in science as assumptions
okay so you say let us assume
so we don't say i know god exists or i
believe that god exists or don't doesn't
exist or i don't know that god exists we
don't say anything like that we say let
us assume
that god exists that's the scientific
way of presenting god
uh in a scientific context and people
say god in a scientific context yeah
exactly just like you hear it
you can bring any assumption into
science
okay any assumption is fine now people
might question your assumption but
there's nothing wrong with saying let us
assume that god exists because you're
going to explain what's going through
your head and i want to understand
what's
what you have going through your mind to
understand your version of how the
universe came to be or why the universe
works this way etc
okay so i need to understand your
version of of how uh the universe works
or how it came to be okay and for that
you have to begin somewhere and you say
let us assume god exists you can't say i
know that god exists and i believe that
god exists
now we don't care about what you believe
or know we care about your assumptions
because that's what we're going to
criticize
uh if that's what you introduce into
your dissertation
okay and uh here's the wikipedia and uh
the dictionary okay here's the
dictionary.com belief is an opinion or a
conviction
it's something you are convinced of
that's all it is
which means knowledge so far we're
talking about knowledge because you're
convinced of what you know
until someone shows you that you were
wrong it turns out your wife or your
husband did not sleep with your next
door neighbor as you
knew turns out you believed it all along
very strongly and you call that
knowledge okay
confidence in the truth or existence of
something
do you know uh for a fact uh the
existence of mediators between atoms
do you know this this these invisible
intangible
particles waves
ropes
that
are between atoms can we see them can we
prove them
can we
make them visible intangible
so do you know that light is mediated by
particles do you know that light is
mediated by waves
do you know that light is mediated by
ropes electromagnetic ropes as we hold
in this site no we don't know that we
make an assumption we say let us assume
light is mediated by
uh particles
no problem there
and then you explain your theory based
on that assumption that's how it works
in science
okay
and confidence faith trust that's what
belief is it's just confidence you have
certain certitude
in what you're saying you believe it
strongly that's all it is
you know so you say well i don't just
believe it i know it what did you say
you just say you believe it more
strongly than just belief
and you say well i have a justification
for it well justification also is a
belief who justified it you
you justified your your knowledge
your belief
okay so to say justification and truth
you haven't said anything all you said
is that you continue to you believe and
believe that's all you introduced so far
a religious tenet or tenets religious
creed or faith yeah people identify
belief with
uh faith with religion
and we're gonna include knowledge also
under religion because knowledge is
belief
and if knowledge is belief
and belief belongs to religion
we're done
knowledge is a word that belongs
exclusively to religion and has no place
whatsoever in science
even though science is defined or
originated the etymology of the word
originating in the notion of no of
knowledge
that was the air that our forefathers
made that's why we have to clean our
nose holes
you know with what our forefathers came
up with because they screwed it up from
the start and they said science uh you
know from syria which uh in that means
knowledge or to know
that was a false step we had a we
started out on the wrong foot okay
science has nothing at all to do with
knowledge its religion has to do with
knowledge because knowledge is believed
science has to do with theories with
explanations and understanding that's
why in this site we say that science is
rational explanations
not
knowledge
okay it's got nothing to do with knowing
okay and then wikipedia says belief is
an attitude
an attitude okay
that something is the case
yeah again
an attitude you have this sense that
it is true to you okay or that some
proposition about the universe is true
true what is true true is what your is
your opinion for me i have a different
truth and your truth is false to me
okay and i can play devil's advocate
extreme devil's advocate and show you
that even pi you know uh
circumstance divided by uh diameter is
untrue is false
and you say no but it's true let me show
you and i keep saying no no no no no no
it's not true it's false and what are
you gonna do
i keep saying it's false okay so this is
the issue i can continue saying that
it's false walls false
all along and you haven't proven it to
me and so what have we learned okay it's
false
okay philosophers use the term belief to
refer to attitudes about the world which
can be either true or false if they can
be false then uh
you know
again we're talking about belief
if they can be false then
so soaking knowledge now this can be
false
and so again we have not distinguished
between
knowledge and belief
okay um
here's a couple
examples that people gave me okay
because they want to defend the notion
that knowledge is something other than
belief
fella says famous statement from feynman
richard feynman right spelled it wrong
uh it is important to realize that in
physic today we have no knowledge of
what energy is these are exact textual
works uh words from mr feinman okay
and he says replace knowledge with the
synonym believe indicated by bill okay
let's do that it is important to realize
that in physics today we have no belief
again spelled it wrong of what energy is
it says do you think they have the same
meaning
well my answer is yes they have the same
meaning until you define the word
knowledge we won't know
why you think they're different
you need to define the word knowledge
you don't
put an example and say do you think
they're the same do you think they're
different
no no define knowledge and we'll know
right
from your definition
whether you know objectively whether
we can replace the word knowledge with
the word belief in finance statement
so all you have to do is very simple
just define the word knowledge and we'll
know what you are talking about we'll
have a definition we'll have in a we can
objectively determine okay whether we
can replace
uh knowledge with belief
and he continues says what are words for
uh
if not to express a generic notion which
is specified and determined in the
context of a sentence
changing the meaning of words only
produces confusion and disorientation
distraction and bewilderment
uh i'm not the one who's changing the
definition you are
you're trying to tell me that knowledge
is not belief when knowledge is defined
everywhere since the days of plato as
belief
so you are the one who are trying to
change the definition but for that you
have only one recourse and that is to
define the word knowledge before you
open your mouth
okay so put a definition there and then
you can make all your case then you can
do whatever you want after that you can
justify explain
you know do whatever you want do your
dissertation until you define the word
knowledge we have no idea what's going
through your tiny brain
okay
so uh yeah don't tell me that uh i'm
redefining i'm doing exactly the
opposite i'm not redefining the word
knowledge i'm telling you what it's been
defined as for the last three thousand
years and what it is defined as today
and that is as belief
knowledge is belief i did not invent
that that is the definition today
anywhere you look at it okay and so
until you define the word knowledge
other than what we have out there in the
encyclopedias in the dictionaries we
have no idea what you are talking about
okay so you are
the the ball is in your court your you
have the task of defining the word
knowledge
another fellow says the following he
says the existence of a god is both
unknown
and unknowable and provides a logical
reason to be to being agnostic
concerning religious beliefs
um
now we have this this my reply to that
okay
all beliefs are religious okay so there
is no such thing as a religious belief
all beliefs are religious and knowledge
you know the unknown and the unknowable
falls within religion okay that's the
first thing we we need to absolutely
make clear why because knowledge is
defined as belief and there you have it
religion is equal to belief and opinion
what is agnosticism well it's got the
you know the agnosticism deals exist uh
exclusively with knowledge or belief the
knowledge
of whether god exists or not the belief
of whether god exists or not that's what
agnosticism is it's a doubt about the
knowledge of the existence of god so
agnosticism deals with the words
knowledge and belief and therefore it's
religion as well just like atheism and
theism or deism okay
existence has nothing to do with unknown
or unknowable or knowledge or what to
know existence is that we as we define
it here is physical presence you have to
have an object and that has to have
location if an object has location it
exists pursuant to the definition of
exist okay
and uh to talk about the knowledge or
the belief in existence is what is
irrational that's why atheism theism and
agnosticism all three are irrational
postures
they're they're rational positions
because they're talking about the belief
in the existence and it turns out that
existence has makes no provision
for belief or for knowledge
okay
do you believe that the chair that chair
you're sitting on
exists
well hopefully you believe in it because
if you don't believe in it what you fall
on your butt to the floor
so does belief or knowledge
have anything to do with
the existence of the chair
that's the issue
and the issue is no you can't say you
believe
or know that the chair is there
what do you mean you know that the chair
is there what does that mean
does it mean that you believe that you
are you strongly believe that the chair
is there is that all you're saying
that you believe and you say no no i
know it's there okay define knowledge
define what you mean by no
when we when you define it then we can
use the word consistently in science
okay then we can say yeah
now we can say that we know that the
chair exists okay
but until you define
knowledge to know we have no idea what
you said all you said you believe that
the chair is there that's the first
issue and then the second issue is that
the word existence has nothing to do
with that anyways you can't say you
believe you know that the chair is there
the chair is there by definition because
existence means
object that has location
is the chair an object yes does it have
location does it have distance with
respect to all matter in the universe to
with respect to every atom in the
universe the answer is yes then it
exists by definition not because you
believe or because you know
okay so it's this notion of introducing
knowledge and belief into the word
existence that is irrational and that's
where atheism theism and agnosticism
fail that's where they are irrational
and um
here we have another fella he says any
scientific proof of your ropes yet bill
uh these fellows you know these uh
electric universers and flat earthers
they're all the same they think
everything has to be proven
and proven through an experiment
they have this notion that we've had for
the last 400 years since the 17th
century so-called scientific revolution
in which measurement experiments
were introduced in addition to more
sophisticated math equations they think
it's a question of doing a measurement
getting an equation and
running another experiment taking more
measurements more equations that they
think that's what science is all about
we've been doing that for 400 years we
have great equations in fact we've
developed mathematics to
irrational levels to
ridiculous levels surrealistic levels
and we have only irrational definit um
explanations for
physical mechanisms
okay so this is the problem so these
people are looking for some proof they
want me to
make them believe
in the rope
we don't do that in science we don't
twist your arm until you believe
okay so they want a scientific i like it
they say scientific proof
so uh
here's the uh
uh uh
there's another fallout i'm gonna get
into that in a second but there's no
such thing as scientific proof
those are that's an oxymoron okay
proof
belongs exclusively to religion whenever
you mention the word proof
evidence you're talking about religion
because when you're talking about
convincing someone persuading them to
change their mind
okay that's the the purpose of evidence
what does a prosecutor introduce a trial
he introduces evidence
what for
is it to prove to the jury
meaning to convince them to sway
the jury in his favor
yeah of course that's the purpose of
evidence is to persuade it's not to
prove knowledge to
to
certified knowledge because when you do
that all you did was again certify
belief you're saying i believe that
that's what happened turns out the
defense attorney has a different version
of what happened and he's got a
different set of assumptions
a different set of
knowledgeable what he knows is different
so he makes a different set of
assumptions
and he's going to try to con sway the
jury convince the jury you know in his
favor
okay of what happened
and so what have we learned
again uh
science is not a trial like in law
that's different okay you do not uh
carry out a trial like we do
in the legal profession okay whenever
they say they've proven they presented
evans they proved
they sent the person to
you know life in prison or the electric
chair it turns out they find out later
on that he was innocent so that proof
only proved that the people who knew the
jurors and the prosecutors they were
wrong
they did not know they believed it turns
out dna showed that this guy was
innocent
so what did we know okay what did we
prove
at trial
so science doesn't work like a trial
okay science we do it objectively that's
the only way to have uniformity across
the planet and the way we do that is
again we explain so that you understand
not so that you believe so we don't run
any experiments and and anyways what
experiment are you going to run
with something that is invisible and
intangible
okay
uh here here we have my famous test okay
everybody knows it by heart by now
that's been following we let go of the
pen okay and it falls to the floor
gravity we call it something called
gravity apparently this whole process we
call it gravity something is pulling or
pushing the pen to the floor
do you see or touch anything
above or below the pen
other than air has anything come in
contact with a pen
well hopefully something came in contact
with a pen because otherwise you're
going to explain this phenomenon
with black magic you're saying there's
nothing that came in contact with a pen
but the pen always falls down it doesn't
fall upwards to to the sky to the
ceiling
so what have we proven with you know
this scientific proof that this fellow
is requesting what does he expect to
find something that he can see or touch
he wants to go to the lab and have some
proof
evidence
so that he's convinced that he believes
that the ropes are there
that the particles are there that the
waves you know electromagnetic waves
vectors
are there
of course so that's what all these
electric universers and uh flat earthers
don't understand you cannot
prove you cannot have evidence you
cannot go to the lab and see and touch
that which is invisible and intangible
the mediators that mother nature uses to
do her daily work and if you say that
there are no mediators you are doing
everything with black magic
known as action at a distance you're
doing things by remote control
and saying what that angels spirits uh
do the mediation how does that thing
over there know that that it's supposed
to fall to the floor
how did it learn that
hopefully something is in contact with
that thing for it to fall always to the
earth gravity is mediated by physical
entities that we cannot see or touch
there is no experiment that you can run
to prove to you know uh to this file
that um there are mediators
okay
this the only way to uh do this is to
visualize you have to visualize how
mother nature could be doing this magic
trick
that you cannot see or touch the
mediators that we cannot see or touch
okay along the same line the next file
also says something similar he says the
following
uh we go
have you got any actual practical
demonstrations
of water miraculously curving and
clinging to the outside of spinning
wobbling gyrating sphere flying through
infinite space
maybe you should read ain't rand
okay uh well i don't know if good old
ain't rand would agree with him first of
all okay uh i don't think she would she
would be in line with him probably more
in line with me
but that's aside from that uh first of
all you know the flat earthers they have
curved water
uh
in in their world because they always
draw a circle they say it's flat but
it's
most of them say it's a circle some say
it's infinite but okay whatever
you've got different flat earthers out
there but most of them say that it's a
circle meaning that water is curved
anyways
why is it curved if there's no container
on the outside
and so they put this ice cap around they
said what's the ice cap you know that's
the container of the water on the planet
well why is the ice cap curved
what curve i mean what is ice if not
water
it froze
how did it get curved before it froze
okay so yeah water is curved even in the
flat earth world but these people have
never figured that out
okay but anyways you know again um i
showed them that uh you know you don't
prove these things
uh you cannot go in there and say i'm
gonna prove that water is curved i
showed that the other day that um
all atoms you know uh if if you look at
that white stuff there and you consider
that uh blue circle as a
sphere instead of a circle okay if
that's a sphere and the
white stuff there is um air why doesn't
the air leave
you know the earth what what keeps it
uh
tied to the earth and i'm saying the
only way you can explain it is if every
atom that constitutes the molecules of
air are bound physically bound through
in this case electromagnetic ropes to
every atom uh that constitutes the uh
the global earth the globular
earth
that's the only way you can explain
gravity
weight you know mass
all these things the only way you can
deal with that is if every atom is
physically interconnected to all other
atoms and the issue there is that the
establishment always use discrete
particles and that's why you cannot
explain it with particles because then
there you could argue that you know
unless you have a container all these
things fly
apart but with my uh assumption which is
the electromagnetic ropes you can't do
that
so this is a different site that says
that all the atoms are physically
interconnected
if all atoms are physically
interconnected now you cannot say that
you need a container
okay
no container is necessary in space all
you need is that all atoms are
physically interconnected
once you understand that you have to
attack a new theory a new a set of
assumptions which is interconnectivity
so don't treat this site like you would
attack the establishment we're not
quantum mechanics we don't we clean our
noses with relativity and strength
theory here okay
this is a different site we're saying
all atoms are physically interconnected
if they're physically interconnected you
can understand why the atoms don't fly
out into outer space you do not need a
container
okay we got that
okay uh let's get to some of the moonies
okay we have the moonies where the
moonies moonies are people who uh
believe that man did not land on the
moon
and so one fell says space is fake
i like that face space is fake what do
you mean it's fake
you can either you you can define space
but say that space is fake what does
that possibly even mean
okay
and he says the iss is in a pool and a
green screen augmented reality studio
provides the comedy you see broadcast
via
nasa's iss live channel okay so he
believes it's all green screened
okay and uh
he says nasa is not a space agency i
like that
the issue is
again i ask all these people to do one
thing and one thing only and they don't
want to do that they just want to argue
because they're talking about the deep
uh
state okay they're concerned about
politics
everybody's an expert in politics
we all are expert in politics because
that's belief
and so we all have our beliefs our
recommendations of how things should be
run i talked about ayn rand all she had
was recommendations how how the world
should be run that's all she did in her
life she didn't do anything beyond that
and so yeah you might
sympathize with her opinions that's fine
no problem but to say that she had
anything to do with science or physics
or philosophy that's where the error is
and the same here
you know you're saying um
you know if you're talking about the
deep state the fact that the government
has fooled you so many times run so many
false flags and that you are going to
throw the baby with a wash water you
won't believe in anything that comes out
of the government well you're taking it
to the other extreme okay
uh nasa i have no reason to believe that
they would
have a what 70 80 year now uh
hoax
running hoax saying that they never sent
a single rocket into space they never uh
have anything any
rocket orbit the earth they never sent
the rocket to the moon they forget about
humans you know i mean here we have the
iss out there and that's one thing that
you can verify
you can verify with a pair of binoculars
or a telescope why don't you do that why
talk about politics and all the fake
news and all that stuff which has
nothing to do with science
just go get yourself a pair of
binoculars point them at the sky
where the uh schedule of nasa which is
published out there tells you that the
thing is going to be out there and just
point your binoculars to it now if it
doesn't pass near your your where you
live ask a friend somewhere to look for
it and see you know
if he can see it out there if it passes
over his head
but to say that it ain't out there at
all that's because that's like you know
the uh
cardinals that didn't want to look
through uh galileo's telescope at the
galilean moons
okay
uh like i refuse to look through your
scope because i don't want uh my
religion to fail right now i'll just
continue believing in the bible right
and that's more or less your your
posture you're saying i'm gonna believe
that there's an iss out there orbiting
the earth i'm just gonna go with my
belief which is that and what other
people tell me authority you know other
great researchers out there who say oh
the iss is a hoax and what space is fake
i'll go with those people i like those
people right okay so you don't believe
that the iss is out there when all it
takes is just looking through galileo's
might a telescope you know that's all
you got to do
okay uh fella says okay says uh the only
observation that lead leads you to state
that water makes globules
in uh space is the one in the iss
and he's referring to this lady that
astronaut who's in the iss and she lets
go of a drop of water or it just comes
out of her toothbrush right and um and
she swallows it okay and you can see the
the
drop of water
has shape
okay even though it has no container
other than the air you could say right
but it there is no container per se
and air you know supposedly is not a
container i don't think you can say that
i mean all the molecules of air would
tend to go outwards not you know towards
a central point so there's no reason to
think that air any more than that water
drop uh are encapsulated in some kind of
container okay
and uh so you know i show this other
clip there the one you see on the upper
left the astronaut releasing a drop of
water in space so he's
questioning this he says so whether do
you discount that all roast from the
water to the atoms in the iss
i don't discount them uh this guy's
misunderstanding everything okay
so he says that seems to make no sense
whatsoever yeah because he didn't
understand okay he thinks that uh
that drop of water
that you see there including the one
from the astronaut that they're not
connected to the astronaut and that that
drop of water is not connected to the
lady astronaut there or to any of the
atoms that form the iss
yes the the drop of weather is connected
to everything in that room okay it is
connected okay so
uh what you don't understand is gravity
okay that's why
uh that's why you ask this
question you say it makes no sense to
you whatsoever because you do not
understand the rope model of gravity
okay
and what we're see you you have to
understand newton's equation to
understand
uh the strength of gravity which is what
you're questioning okay that the drops
of water every atom in that in both of
those drops of water are connected to
everything in the universe
in the unit to every atom in the
universe okay they're all connected what
you don't understand is uh the inverse
square law uh
newton's equation gravitational equation
universal gravitational equation so
that's what you got to look at if you
don't have enough mass okay there's not
quantity of atoms
nearby the drops
then it floats around okay
more or less depending also on certain
context certain situations i think
that's the
uh next issue here
and these people say the following this
is another person who questions the iss
he says oh i discovered something here
that
escaped the directors of the
uh studio version of the iss okay that
we're talking about hollywood here okay
they think there's
no iss out there they don't think
there's anybody on the iss floating
around and so this is this is what
someone
flat earther or
electric universe or he discovered this
he knows this for a fact and here it is
he says uh
the water in that glass should be
floating and he's showing that glass
that's on the table there okay
and you can see that the water is not
coming out of the glass which is what he
thinks should be happening
and so i i counter that and say where in
the world did you get the idea that the
water in that glass should be floating
he thinks it should be floating like the
drop that you just saw floating without
a container okay that's the issue
and uh i think there's something more uh
you know more more evident more obvious
and it's uh that the
um
this in question why the three
astronauts are not floating i mean
they're standing on the ground on the
floor of the iss why aren't they
floating forget about the water why
aren't they floating around and you know
jumping around
and uh
and so if he can't answer that question
forget about the water then uh i asked
him also you know uh making fun of him
saying they're not wearing helmets
either i mean they're you know how can
they breathe up there you know and then
uh
all that high vacuum that you have up
there the lungs should be exploding and
should there be it shouldn't they be
zapped by the solar wind and other rocks
and minerals that the sun throws at the
earth i mean these people are so
ignorant that's what they are they are
ignorant people they don't do any
research on this before asking the
question
they just go out there and whatever
comes to their mind they just say oh
this looks obvious to me
you know and so
what can you do if they don't understand
basic physics
they should do a lot more physics unless
politics politics is opinion
they don't understand that they they're
worried about the deep state and what
the
illuminati are doing to them they're
going to corral them and put them in as
slaves in uh in the future they're
worried about all that stuff a lot of
them are narco capitalists who believe
that there's too much
uh intervention by the state in your
life and so they do a lot of politics
they don't do any research on physics
and they bring all their politics
nonsense into physics that's what's
happening and so they say oh look at
this they're trying to fool us
they're worried about the uh fake news
about the uh false flags and not about
the physics of it that's where the
problem comes in so so they pass as
ignorant people that's all they do is
ignoramuses
okay uh
along the same line someone says
the film used for the photographs and
for the films of the apollo missions
referring to especially to apollo 11
worked in the ultra vacuum of 10 to the
minus 12 torr remember if they're on the
moon you're talking about 12 to 13 uh
minus 12 to the 13 torr level meaning
almost perfect vacuum at least from from
the earth's point of view not perfect
but
it's getting there right very few
particles per
cubic centimeter
and
you look it up and this is one of the
answers you find out there the film
itself was normal photographic film
although a special emotion made
specifically for nasa
not a space agency
it wasn't some super exotic photographic
film printed on an
unobtainium base
it was standard acetate film with a
gelatin emotion
and then another fella asked is it
possible to use the camera in low
pressure or vacuum and someone answered
there the camera itself can work in
vacuum a few issues have to be addressed
internal temperature sensors should be
monitored some electronic components may
be overheated because there is no
convective cooling
outgassing of glue and lubrication may
occur
depending on estimating up estimated
operating time in vacuum modification of
the camera must be considered instead of
modifying the camera environment
enclosure can be used
okay so there are answers to this
fella's question
and uh again it's uh people looking for
like we say in spanish uh the hair on
the egg
to try to figure out how they can uh
debunk the uh
the space program meaning
man landing on the moon
and i keep saying you know
first of all
no analysis of the films will get your
argument through
why because
you will not be able to convince anyone
on earth okay
even yourself
that
uh
the difference between the actual moon
landing and the thing done in a uh
studio
you can't you cannot because if you can
reproduce man landing on the moon with
the studios you cannot tell the
difference between any of those so any
errors that you find
well you know then you're criticizing
the
director of the movie you're saying that
the roman gladiator
who
has
you know a wrist watch
the director didn't notice it and let it
go in into the movie
that he made such a
uh you know gaping error
you know you do you think that
nasa didn't hire the top guys to make
the movie if that's what they did and if
they did they're going to check
everything they're going to check the
shadows the
stars in the background and the jumping
and they're going to check everything
they're going to make sure everything is
perfect they're not going to let a
single
little detail go through
that makes you doubt
and for people to say oh look at all
these errors that they made the stars in
the background the jumping it's all
wrong and the lighting is wrong the
shadows
if they've made so many errors something
is wrong with your understanding
okay you have a problem
you can't find so many errors and say
they made all these errors okay that's
one nation the other one issue is if you
can't tell the difference if you cannot
tell me what the difference is between a
film made in a studio of the landing on
the moon and the actual landing on the
moon you don't have a case
you don't have a case you have to be
able to distinguish between those if you
can which i think you can't okay
then you don't have a case
and again and what i ask people to do is
go out there and look at the iss
the international space station if it's
floating if it's orbiting out there
uh
you got to tell me how that monster that
football field sized object got up there
how did they get it up there weren't
there certain steps that they had to
take to get that thing up there
and if they had to take steps then that
means that they nasa
space agencies uh around the world they
did send rockets out into space
certainly they had to put satellites out
there except the flat earthers who don't
believe even that they had to put the
satellites out there how did they get
those satellites out there how did they
get you know uh
the iss out there
if you can't answer that if you don't
say if you say well there weren't any
prior steps that they just one day you
know they had a headache and they said
ah why don't we send some rockets uh the
iss up there one shot
is that what you're saying
and if the iss is up there obviously
they had many steps among them you know
that they had to send rockets into space
okay in this case they use the shuttles
to take parts up there and build it into
in space you can't just send this
football field up sized object into
space
so you gotta explain it you're gonna
find out all the steps that they had to
take even if you don't believe there are
people inside the iss some people don't
believe that part
but you gotta explain the iss
so if you if you wanna if you wanna deny
the iss because you don't wanna get your
binoculars your telescope well you know
all bets are off you know we don't even
have a starting point so these are
things you gotta check out
okay uh phil says
a sphere is a is the flattest shape that
can naturally occur in the universe
i see his flat okay
uh here's my thought of the day okay
let's see what he's got suppose part of
the universe contains two particles
moving parallel in time towards the
future okay well they diverge in space
time without the presence of any
external influence if yes such a space
has hyperbolic curvature is this correct
see these people want to
talk about structure using motion
okay this is where the problem is they
say
they want to talk about parallel for
example by moving
and that's the version of religion of
mathematical physics that's not the
version of science okay so they're
starting already on the wrong foot
so uh here's my answer to what is he
this fellow raises
okay
it is in the religion of mathematics you
know mathematical physics where they
determine that space time is spherical
by going around in circles
in physics we point to a sphere
therefore we do not run an experiment to
determine whether vacuum is hyperbolic
straight or crooked instead we define
the key words that make or break our
arguments and theories
and here are the two key words here
space that which has no shape nothing
vacuum or synonyms okay
and parallel what is parallel
equidistant surfaces it's not
equidistant itineraries which is what
the this fella is referring to
peril is an adjective for the purposes
of physics not ordinary speech not
mathematics not religion okay
in in physics parallel is an adjective
in physics adjectives can only be used
to qualify objects
itineraries are not things therefore it
is irrational in physics to say
that something is moving parallel to
something else
okay that's ordinary speech that is
mathematics
okay so please learn the language learn
the language because you're confusing
language of ordinary speech and you're
bringing it into science without even
understanding it
casually you don't you don't realize it
you gotta analyze the words
okay
we have a new language in this site and
unless you learn the language of physics
you're gonna be introducing language of
ordinary speech especially the words
exist the word object and in this case
motion
thinking that parallel has to do
something with motion
you know they say parallel lines which
are extended
infinitely they don't meet
so they say it's parallel and they say
well how do you know it's parallel well
go to infinity and find out if they meet
come back when you when you finish
getting to infinity
and so it's a it's an open-ended
definition you can't use that definition
in science but the mathematicians they
they're not they don't know anything
about definitions
so they define it like that and they say
okay that sounds all right to me and
that's what they use
no in science only physical objects can
be said to be
parallel we're talking about the
surfaces of those two objects and they
have to be equidistant throughout if it
meets that definition they are parallel
you do not say
i'm going to
travel along the surface
and find out you know if
the two lines meet
the itineraries meet and so that's why
this hyperbolic nonsense uh that
relativity brings up that you know you
you either go around the universe in
circles parallel without meeting the two
lines or if they diverge then you have
hyperbolic uh universe or whatever
that's nonsense that's that's
mathematics
they want to do it with equations and
what are equations equations are always
itineraries
okay what they're talking about is
motion
they're describing motion they're not
explaining anything with that
yeah and they're not defining an object
when you wanna
uh
talk about an object you have to point
to it
you point to what a sphere okay and you
say sphere
that's how it works you point to a cube
and you say
cube
and so now the e.t understands your
language he knows what a cube is he
knows what a sphere is you don't say let
me run around the circle let me round
around
uh the cube and tell you whether it's
straight parallel hyperbolic or whatever
that's mathematics and the nonsense of
mathematics
okay another foul brings up the issue of
my spoon falling okay
and uh he says look the there there uh
you see the spoon falling okay how do we
explain that in uh
in science in uh
especially in this site and under the
rope model or here it is we're saying
that this spoon is falling
because uh every atom of the spoon is
bound to every atom
on the earth
and so we have a physical entity that is
connecting the earth to every atom of
the spoon that's why the spoon doesn't
go in the opposite direction towards the
sky because there's a lot more matter
bound uh below it than it there is above
it the closest object out there is the
moon and it's too far away to have any
influence on that spoon okay so that's
how we explain it so what does this
fellow say he says the following he says
the spoon will fall if you let go of it
since it's heavier
than the air which surrounds it there's
no need for space robes
uh
we ask them what physical object is in
contact with the spoon here you have the
spoon okay
and it falls to the floor it falls
downwards
what physical object is pushing or
pulling on the ro on the on the spoon
that's the question
and he says it's heavier
that's a concept you have not explained
what is in contact with the skin
of the spoon
okay and another fellow also another
flat earther he has the same thing he
says get a helium balloon and let it go
and it goes up
okay
versus the spoon going down okay yeah
wouldn't relative density
dogs about what physical object now he's
talking about a concept known as density
which he has no idea what it means
be an explanation that more real world
than your ropes that's more real world
than your ropes
density you have not explained why the
spoon
falls to the floor by saying density or
heavier you have to explain
density you have to explain heavy er
okay this is the issue
and so here let me give you some
homework that you can work on so you
know what what you have to answer
instead of
using these words heavier in density
this is what you got to answer okay you
have a bowling ball
and the farther it is from the earth the
less it weighs
okay and the closer it is to the earth
the more it weighs you can determine
that with a scale you put it on the
scale you know and you'll find out that
the one farther out weighs less than the
one closest by
uh if you could go to mount everest you
could weigh something there and
something at the bottom of mount everest
or at sea level and you'll find out that
it weighs less at the top at the tip of
mount everest that's how simple it is
now let's remove the scale momentarily
and we say the following what is it that
compels the bowling ball to fall to
earth why doesn't that bowling ball
continue flying out into space why does
it fall to earth
that's what you get explained you can't
say it's heavier you can't say it's
density
you have to explain what is in physical
contact with the bowling ball if you say
that there is nothing there you are
explaining gravity with
black magic that's the issue
hopefully there is a physical object
that you cannot see or touch that
mediates gravity that's the issue before
us
okay so all these flat earthers they
don't even know what what the question
is they don't even know what they have
to answer so they say well it's heavier
it's denser
what have you said you haven't said
anything okay
okay uh
another
um visitor i think lady uh says the
following uh
uh talking again about flat earthers
here
oh mr foolish man referring to me okay
please explain why russia is supposed to
be 55 miles from the edge of alaska and
yet takes 29 hours to get there
it took her 29 hours to get from alaska
to russia
poor lady
all right if you lay the map flat rush
is still
the way over to the right
are these people for real it took her 29
hours to get from alaska to russia
that's that's just unbelievable you know
i don't know maybe she took the pony
express to the through the ocean
i have no idea uh poor lady
i think she should sue the the
corporation that
she hired to
make that trip maybe she should um
you know sue them get her money back
my god
okay another fellow flat earther says
knowledge is not equal to truth okay
globe belief
requires a suspension of disbelief
similar to that when we watch a movie
gravity is just a math concept
okay that has never been demonstrated to
be a real force
poor fellow i mean i just demonstrated
uh showing that you know the
spoon falls to the floor okay but he
says it's never been demonstrated other
than a mathematical concept
it has not ever been demonstrated to
hold air under pressure
and so earth is demonstrably a level
plane we have woken up bill
yeah these people believed in pressure
and they talk about pressure at all
moments in time why because they are
talking about particles and so they say
well gases tend to fly apart
and if you remove the glass the water in
the glass immediately falls you know
spreads out so they say you need a
container
because they're thinking of discrete
particles that's the issue
and we're saying in this site we're
talking about something different we're
saying that all atoms are physically
connected to the earth including every
atom in your body the reason you jump
and fall back to earth is you're
connected to earth physically connected
that's different than what mathematical
physics says that's different than what
quantum mechanics general relativity and
string theory say
in those religions they have discrete
particles
and so if you're thinking about discrete
particles you say well unless you
contain them
you know they fly apart
that's not the case in this
channel in this channel we're talking
about something else we're saying that
all atoms are connected to the earth
physically connected to the earth that's
why you don't need a container and there
you see
an example
you see the water which is the dark blue
and you see the air which is that the
lighter blue that you see there
different shades of it okay we're going
to take one atom of the air just one
atom okay and if it's connected to every
atom on earth you can see why it doesn't
fly outside the earth and why you don't
need a container to keep it there it's
there because it's connected to the
earth do you understand or or do you
have mental problems
it's connected physically connected to
the earth
and all atoms you can see in the air
that belong to the air are all connected
to the earth so is every atom of that
blue water the one that forms the oceans
of earth they're all connected to every
atom on earth so if you have one atom on
one side of the earth yeah for example
one of those air atoms
and
it's connected to the atoms on the other
side of the earth you can see why it
doesn't fly away it's physically
attached to the earth
okay just like you are attached to the
earth
okay
now you say well i can't see it i can't
touch it yes it's invisible and
intangible
and people say well hold it you're
talking about it you're invisible in
tanzania how do you know it's there how
do you believe it's there
we don't believe we make an assumption
we say let us assume that all atoms are
physically interconnected
and one of the issues there is that they
question the rope model they say well i
don't see the ropes i can't touch the
ropes i can't run an experiment to prove
their existence
but then when quantum talks about
discrete particles
two particles being at the same place at
the same time or one particle being at
two places at once they never question
that
i mean have you ever questioned quantum
mechanics
okay when they say that light consists
of discrete particles
have you ever seen those particles have
you seen the photons
have you touched the photons
do you know for a fact that there are
four that light is made of photo
discrete little balls
and the answer is no is gravity the
mediator of gravity made of discrete
balls
okay so nobody questions it the only
question when you bring the rope and
they say well how come i can't see or
touch it well you can't see or touch the
balls the
gravitons with which they you they
explain
gravity have you ever questioned that
why do you think quantum mechanics
cannot explain gravity
because you cannot explain pull
with little discrete stones
assuming they were stoned which are not
but that's the second issue
but nobody questions that they say i
can't see or touch the stones but nobody
questions that they but as soon as you
say the rope uh an elongated object say
well why can't i see and touch this
elongated object why can't you see and
touch the particles that are flowing
between those two objects
have you ever thought about that about
the question
okay and this is the issue
okay and final issue here with a flat
earther earth was a star comet is based
on a theory called stellar metamorphosis
by jeffrey wolinski
absolutely not
okay wellinski did not come up with this
theory he usurped it as his
okay alexander o'barron he was a soviet
uh
biologist was the originator of the
theory that the earth was once a star
wolinski is taking credit for something
he did not develop or originate you will
find more information about this issue
in the video titled
uh earth is older than the sun it's a
video that i have out there so you can
look at big 80 okay
and you'll find the earth is older than
the sun okay where i explain
um
that first i gave credit to wolinski
because i thought he was the originator
when i did a little research after i
made the video
um
you know i realized that he was not the
originator i did not uh re uh remove the
video because the
video talks about two things and that's
why all
celestial objects are spherical instead
of flat as flat earthers say
and why they are um differentiated why
there are layers okay and so what we're
tearing to pieces is the
nebular hypothesis which is used for the
sun it's okay but when they talk about
the planets no the nebular hypothesis
does not explain the
the origin of the planets and the moons
of some of these planets like jupiter's
moons and saturn's moons and so that's
what the video is about the fact that i
originally gave credit to wolinski i
corrected that in the description of the
video
and there's no reason for me to take it
out you know you reach your own
conclusions okay so
uh but wilinsky is not the originator
and in fact he's got only irrational
explanations for everything so it
doesn't matter anyways what lindsay
comes up with
okay uh about that philosophy
we're going to go into the questions now
people made throughout the week
philosophy deals with
the rational reasons and purposes and of
concepts and behavior okay is that more
important than determining what object
technically exists anywhere momentarily
well whether it's important or not is
unimportant okay so we don't care about
important because that's an opinion okay
objects only experience reality or
existence temporarily okay
such existence may not compare to in to
the permanent nature of fundamental
concepts well the problem is that exists
has nothing to do with permanent or with
uh temporary at all there's no
issue of time in the word
exist that's where the problem comes in
with this fellow's uh argument
um exists object that has location
location is timeless in other words
it's a static concept
okay so you can't talk about temporary
or permanent
okay location has nothing to do with
with time
okay
and so
introducing time in here is what is
irrational
and he continues surely you must grant
that the branch of science you
particularly define as philosophy must
retain the right to define existence in
more subjective and permanent terms
the answer is no
again has nothing to do with what you
got to do is define the word exist and
uh if you think it's got something to do
with um
with the word exists has something to do
with permanent or temporary just define
the word exist in such a way that it
embodies
the concept of time what does
existence have to do with time that's
what you gotta answer and you answer not
by giving a big explanation but by
defining the word exist in such a way
that you include incorporate the word
time or some
notion of time in there
okay uh false says
perhaps god is not an object and has no
shape okay how is this subjective
existence as a concept make him any less
real
now we don't understand what you said
because real is a synonym of exists so
so far we have no idea what you said
okay until you define the word exist
until you define the word real and show
how they're different then
we have no idea what you said
god is not just intangible and invisible
he also has no shape
okay yeah if he has no shame obviously
he's intangible and invisible because he
has no shape obviously he's a concept
by physics definition of yours he
doesn't exist correct
okay
but by a philosophical definition of
existence he most certainly does
where's your definition we don't know
what you're what what's going through
your mind
true philosophers define existence as
that experience which has meaning okay
so that's his definition okay let's find
out if that's
has any validity whatsoever here's the
answer
exists meaningful experience that's what
he's defining exists as okay so does the
chair in japan exist now can you tell me
whether that exists using your
definition there can we determine
through your definition minimum
meaningful experience that a chair in
japan exists
the space exists
i mean using your definition what what
meaningful experience do you have with
uh chair in japan what meaningful
experience you have with space
does the roller coaster ride you
experienced last saturday exist if so in
what way does it exist
does it exist for your friend who did
not experience it
you see how his irrational definition he
just wants to be able to incorporate his
religion in there and so he says it just
means meaningful experience essentially
and so we cannot apply it to
things that exist especially in physics
okay in fact it doesn't even
comply with ordinary speech because
people usually say the chair exists what
does that mean as far as meaningful
experience how how does meaningful
experience
relate to the chair existing
so no meaningful existence is an
irrational definition you can't use it
for anything
he just wants to be able to introduce
his religion that's how he he wants to
justify his religion he says well for me
it means meaningful experience
yeah you said nothing you said an
irrationality that's what you said
okay uh now the father says
how does he's a creationist obviously
because all his issues are related to
creation you see it in every almost in
every sentence he says how does the rope
hypothesis fit with the big bang theory
what is big bang it's the origin of the
universe uh relativists deny it they say
no it doesn't have to do with origin of
the universe it has to do with frame
number two
in in the sequence they don't know what
happened in frame number one they say we
can trace the universe if we pull all
the
uh
galaxies together
go back in time 12 13 billion or 14
billion years ago we end up with a
singularity and we don't know what
happened before that we don't know how
the singularity came to be that's their
argument um but that's where they start
so they start a creation but they don't
want to tell you how it was created how
the
little uh
singularity came into being to begin
with okay and of course religious people
usually accuse traditional religious
people usually accuse them of uh eluding
god saying what you want to allude is
that god created the singularity
okay so he says initially there was pure
energy now there can't be pure energy
because energy is not a physical object
you cannot say there is or there was
okay
you can't say there was because energy
is a concept and concepts were all
created by man and what you're saying is
that man is the creator of the universe
essentially that's what it comes down to
it took some time for various subatomic
particles to form and eventually
coalesce into nuclei and then atoms well
that's the
religion of general relativity which is
apparently accepts on the basis of
authority
so in this sequence he says when did the
rose first appear in this sequence
obviously he's talking about creation
and creationism and we are on record
saying that matter never came into
existence you cannot turn space
into matter you cannot convert nothing
into an atom spontaneously with or
without god okay because when you do
that you have black magic and black
magic
is uh no explanation at all of a
mechanism
was there no gravity before the rose
there's no such thing as before the
ropes matter has always been there okay
so there is no creation
no big bang none of that nonsense which
you're swallowing by authority only
does the reverse happen if you heat
matter to a plasma and beyond can the
roast be destroyed does a black hole
affect the effect of ropes again all
this has to do with creationism that
this fell has in his mind
he continues says the rope hypothesis
assumes we live in a static universe
that may have always existed yeah true
not a static universe we don't know what
that is static universe in the universe
is constantly in motion there's no such
thing as static in the universe not only
matter has always been there but motion
has always been there to to use that
language
what doesn't quite fit right with a
static universe again use that word
static when that's his version okay is
the progression from large short lived
stars okay
which in an earlier video claims earth
is a remnant okay producing heavy
elements to smaller long-lived stars
like our sun
yeah again i have no idea what he's
talking about okay uh it's a this static
thing that he's got in his mind uh
that's um
from people who opposed the official
version the the
one that's out there which says that we
live in some kind of dynamic universe
and we had
some people criticize that and said no
no uh
we believe in a static universe the
creation of matter from nothingness yeah
okay so he's introducing that into the
rope model and that's nonsense we don't
use the word static at all we don't talk
about static universe a pattern like
this fits an aging universe rather than
one that's been static forever well we
don't even have a static universe or an
aging universe okay so both are outside
the bounds of the rope model
this is very simple matter has always
been there
in motion always
and the starting conclusion from that is
that and here you gotta hold on to your
chair and go get like 10 beers to
understand this
because it's going to blow your mind
away
there was never a first human
in the universe
there was never a first human in the
universe
before us in before the earth was here
and created uh
you know we we arose
humans arose here on earth
somewhere somewhen
in the past there was another planet
somewhere in the universe maybe one
right now
that also had humans
okay
and uh before them
there was another planet that also had
humans before then there was another
planet that had humans before then there
was another planet and humans and before
then there was another planet that had
humans and i'm not going to continue
with that line of thinking because
i'll stay here all day and it'll go to
what infinity there was always always
a planet before uh before in any planet
you can imagine
that where there were humans there was
never a first human
on any planet in the universe
okay i hope we understand the problem
okay hopefully that'll keep you up awake
it's not nice
it hasn't kept me up at weights believe
me uh so
matter cannot be created from space
space cannot be converted into matter
matter cannot uh
morph into space and vice versa one
cannot convert it into the other
because if you convert space into matter
or matter into space you're doing black
magic
you cannot tell me what process what
mechanism you
god used the double used to convert
matter into space or space into matter
if you cannot explain the mechanism you
cannot say that matter converts into
space or vice versa
meaning that the notion that the
mathematicians have that there was a big
bang
singularity that simply appeared out of
nowhere which they cannot explain which
they refused to explain frame one in the
universal movie they start their theory
of frame number two that's irrational
because if they say that if you take all
the galaxies and converge upon a
singularity frame number two they have
to explain number uh frame number one no
movie starts at frame number two they
cannot just say well we don't know what
happened in frame number one no because
their
their religion takes them there
uh their argument their theory takes
them to frame number one they have to
explain number one they cannot avoid
that stuff because that's a crucial
uh
frame that they have to explain to say
they're gonna start their movie at frame
number two
is irrational okay and that's just
alluding the question okay yeah the
movie has to start at frame number one
okay uh another foul says he says uh
get this up here considering spacey's
sort of container is unavoidable
okay again thinking particles all these
people i doubt the universe is infinite
okay
why as in you can take one object and
keep increasing its relative distance to
alder others indefinitely
okay so uh what's the answer to that
here it is
okay here's uh
the universe okay according to him
he says that space which is that black
stuff that contains you could say
contain right the matters all those
little dots that you see there that's
the matter in the universe that's that's
our universe right the matter
the black stuff is space he says it's
not infinite he thinks it's finite
he has only one question to answer he
cannot allude this question okay he's
got to tell me what the green stuff is
what gives shape to space if space is
not infinite
it's an object that's a thing it has
shape so therefore something has to be
on on the outside of space giving shape
to space
that's what he's saying okay let's get
it right here it is
let's make sure we understand what he's
saying space is some kind of container
he says it's unavoidable why because he
cannot imagine that you can simply
increase the distance between objects
indefinitely meaning he thinks that
space has a surface
and if it has a surface you have to
identify what's on the outside of it
meaning the green stuff
unless you identify the green stuff you
tell me what that is what physical
object what thing what what entity what
whatever that is
uh you have not
you have eluded the question all you
have is some irrational notion that
space
is uh
finite
and you cannot explain what's outside of
it which is what general relativity says
general relativity says you know uh the
universe is finite they see it as a
sphere that is expanding
and they say it's irrational
or unscientific to ask what's outside of
that what is
space
expanding again or space time expanding
against what is it pushing against
they say it's an irrational question
they say it's an irrational question
because they have no way of proving it
through an experiment
you know or
with measurements or whatever with an
equation
and this is not a question of proof it's
a question of of conception you have to
conceptualize
visualize what's on the outside of it if
you cannot visualize what's on the
outside of it what is it thought that
encapsulates space
if you cannot visualize what's on the
outside of space
then you you have an irrational proposal
you're saying that space has shape but
there's nothing outside of it
and all objects that have shape
hopefully all objects have shaped uh
have some backdrop something that serves
as contrast
okay otherwise it wouldn't have shape it
would be an infinite object meaning
whatever that means that it's expanding
forever you cannot see it from a bird's
eye perspective that's why it doesn't
have shapes it's an object that doesn't
have shape the only object that doesn't
have shape space
no obviously uh it's international
proposal
okay and here we have another you cannot
put two objects in the same place there
is something which disallows it yeah to
tell that to the quantum folk
if you try to force such objects
together they break apart or deform okay
tell that to quantum if you are able to
force two objects to be in the same
location their constituents will
generally need to change or rearrange to
allow it
tell that the quantum mechanics see
quantum mechanics says two particles can
be at the same place at the same time
have you ever learned quantum mechanics
or are you just
guessing uh destroying whatever comes to
your mind
i cannot reach through my cupboard door
to grab a mug i need to open it first
yeah you're talking about macro world
when you talk about the micro world the
invisible intangible micro world then
quantum mechanics says that two objects
can be at the same place at the same
time and that's where you have to uh
take your questions first before you
bring them here okay
you can't get objects to sort of clip
through each other and stamp to some
sort of grid on the other
on the other side correct you can't do
that with macro objects we're talking
about micro you know like light and
magnetism and gravity okay the mediators
of those
phenomena okay
how do the roads pass through each other
again see touch that's what they want to
know that's what
keeps them up awake at night
they connect or merge and get pulled
apart again
so here's the answer okay
so here we go c touch never ask the
question in quantum
have you ever
talked about see and touch when they
talk about
particles in quantum mechanics
in quantum mechanics they say two
particles can be at the same place at
the same time and one particle can be at
two places it never occurred to you to
ask this question in quantum mechanics
so they bring it here because they say
they say oh how can uh two ropes pass
through each other well how can two
particles pass through each other how
can two rows be at the same place at the
same time well how can two particles be
at the same place at the same time what
do you propose
okay please tell me what empty what
physical entity what object what thing
okay
mediates gravity and can you pass your
hand through that object when uh you
know like uh let me put this over here
for a second
okay
here's gravity phenomenon known as
gravity we let go of the spoon it falls
to the floor we know that we call it
gravity
can you see or touch what's below or
above it
is there something pushing is there
something pulling can you see or touch
it
so you're passing so hopefully there's a
physical object there
and i can pass my hand through that
object right here and right here
and you say there's no object because i
cannot see or touch it
then you're doing black magic you're
you're explaining gravity with black
magic you're saying nothing is contact
with the skin of the pen but it always
magically falls down never falls upwards
you don't realize that you're explaining
with black magic if you do not put an
invisible intangible object in that
space
that's where these people
fail in their reasoning that's why they
are irrational individuals
so here i say well how does water pass
through water i mean have you ever tried
that uh take two
uh hoses you know turn them on you know
water going through them and you can you
know play uh you just run the water
right through each other can you do that
i mean you can't do that with two steel
beams
imagine if you could do it with two
steel beams today right it would knock
you out of your feet because you i
didn't know you could run a steel beam
through another one
of course you can't with a steel beam
but it turns out that we have examples
in our everyday world where you can put
gas through gas you know air through air
you can
run liquids through liquids like water
through water
but it never it comes to your mind that
we do have the ability in our macro
world to run things through each other
and you say well they're made of
particles they're made of individual
particles
well do you know that
what holds
um a steel beam together if if the atoms
are not connected what holds water
together even inside a glass you know or
or a gas uh what holds that together
inside a balloon
why doesn't the gas just go outwards
okay
why why is gas connected to gas i mean
you can send a blob of gas in space or
blob of water in space like we showed
and it maintains its structure
in space
what keeps it together if not that all
the atoms are bound to each other
and you say i can't see or touch what
connects one atom to another of course
you can't because c touch is not
the criteria to define the word object
the word thing that's where your error
that's where your rationale your that's
where you are irrational that's where
your
logic fails okay
so yeah uh
you can pass your hand through water
magical you know just go whoa i can pass
the hand through here look let me let me
do this magic trick for you i'm passing
my hand through air
see how
and you never question that
but if i could pass my hand through
this solid spoon then you would say oh
how did he do that one
unless i'm fooling you with some kind of
you know visual trick
how does air pass through air
how does light pass through gravity i
mean here we have gravity right in this
region how is that you can see me
through gravity
i mean
there's something connecting the spoon
to the earth or if you prefer
particles pushing down on the spoon
and you can see me right through
this gravity thingy
how is that possible how can you see me
through
if there's an object here there's a
thing there
and if you say there is no thing here or
here you are using black magic to
explain gravity you're saying that this
spoon falls downwards and there's
nothing in physical contact with the
spoon
that's where your logic fails that's why
you are an irrational
individual is there no thing there uh
you don't see touch how does magnetic
field pass through air
there we have two magnets okay the two
little things there the little let me do
it here with let me remove this for a
second
uh
give me a second here
okay we have two magnets two little
circles there okay
they stick together
magnetism magic
is there nothing between
the two magnets
well you say i can't see or touch
anything in there
i mean you could do this in space it
would still work even though there's in
space there's no
matter like between two galaxies you
could do this and it would still attract
okay there's nothing pushing from the
outside because obviously you know you
just take too many you can feel that
the pull is from the inside it's not
from push from the outside
and so the question is is there anything
in this region
if you say there is nothing there
you are using black magic to explain the
attraction between two magnets
if you say there's a field a magnetic
field you are using irrationality again
because you are saying there's a a
concept called field
bunch of numbers that's what a field is
value at each point in space that's what
the definition of the word field
you're saying there's that because there
are numbers
in space that these two magnets attract
each other
so you have to put a physical object
here or like
mr faraday and mr uh maxwell said
there is something physical in that
region we call
magnetic field some exotic material that
they couldn't figure out what it was
but they said there's something physical
in motion in that region
that we call field it's a region
of numbers
that's why you can't use the word field
in science okay you need to explain it
with a physical object you can say
that there's a an elongated uh wire
between them that you can say you can
argue that you can say there's a tree
you can say there's a dog you need to
use a physical object between the two
magnets
you cannot explain it with a concept you
cannot say there's intelligence between
the two main there's love between the
two magnets that's not a rational
explanation and to say field is the same
thing you're saying that if there's a
concept that draws these two magnets
together you can't do that in physics
okay so there's a physical object that
is drawing these two together you have
to identify what that physical object is
and that thing makes up what we call the
concept known as field
okay so you have to identify the
physical object that's how simple it is
and if you say there's nothing there
you're using black magic you're saying
that there's nothing there but the
magnets are attracted to each other
there's nothing between the spoon and
the earth right or above
and that the spoon always falls to the
floor never to the ceiling
we have to turn the world upside down
for it to fall to the ceiling
what is in contact with a spoon
if you say nothing you are introducing
black magic in your
uh explanation into the mechanism
final question first person says the
third dimension is the only dimension we
can see and touch
so he touches dimensions he can see
dimensions magical eyes that this fellow
has okay he can touch him and see him a
dimension so which one can he see and
touch is it length width or height
those are the three dimensions i don't
know of any other
air is made of 3d atoms
you know air here made of 3d atoms right
hopefully right
can you see
the air on your planet
i mean let me go to your planet
maybe you can see the air over there and
you can tell me you know if you can see
or touch the air because i can't see it
here on
touch maybe but i can't see it
and so
he says the third dimension is the only
dimension we can see
well you know here we have the third
dimension and we can't see it in the air
atoms you know
and then uh all geometric solids are 3d
take for example a cube the ideal cube
of geometry okay that's 3d it's
conceptually 3d it's not 2d it's not 1d
it's not 0d
like the point line and plane right it's
a solid and a solid is known as a 3d
object why because you need 3 axes to
define
you know
in geometry right you need three axes to
conceptualize or define
or represent
a cube okay so as spheres 3d and q has
length width and height can you touch a
cube
here you have a 3d object
okay can you touch it
and the answer is no cubes are ideal
perfect cubes okay i can touch this cube
but this is not a perfect cube this is a
semblance of a cube it's an analogy of a
cube but not a cube okay a rubik's cube
and um and so yeah um
the ideal cube
of geometry is 3d because you need three
axis to conceptualize it define it
represent it etc etc and if it's 3d you
cannot say that you can see
or touch
the third dimension you can't see the 3d
atoms that make up the air and you can't
touch a 3d cube
with that i'll see you next time next
sunday and hopefully
we continue in this line of questioning
uh certain words of philosophy such as
belief knowledge and
we'll see what what we bring up next
time